[Music]
welcome back to dirty RT the show where
we play as the biggest piece of
character possible Jake we're on a new
endeavor here it's been a while
it's been a real long time we're playing
the outer worlds yeah we you've been
playing a good amount of this game and
as you played it you were like this
would be really good for dirty arty so
here we are we're customizing so
intelligence reception below average
charm not much charm no temperament
Oh does this so that's his ability to
lie sneaky
yeah I'd say I'd say hi okay okay
aptitude bureaucrat beverage service
technician farmer dirt all right well I
think that's the winner that's a pretty
good face to start with yeah we got we
were trying to make him at least
somewhat familiar right yeah but he's
got a big old big old dome hair all
right this is now we're talking God what
I mean average ooh I can't go increments
that that's pretty good that one no
sorry the one that the one before that
oh here we go
it's about as much of a beard as we can
get you can you can change that color a
little bit too yeah
whoa we got to age him up a bit right
yeah he's getting pre old dirt obviously
dirt max all right there's her there's
armored dirt covered in dirt that checks
out he's dumb as hell
you
good luck I
[Music]
all the colonists are counting 30 Artie
he picked up he picked a poor colonist
to save everyone I like to imagine
what's his name that doc dr. phinius
yeah Phineas Wells phineas Wells I like
to think that like he picked the wrong
time line oh [ __ ] I've only got one shot
at this you've tried the best now I'll
try the rest
it's a baseless choice oh that stings
Razors what oh we're all part of the
spacers choice family here not that I
deserve to be can't even deliver a
company slogan we were out on patrol
I saw a marauder camp up in the hills
thought I could take him then my gun
misfired rights are on my side I mean
what are the odds of that right
just barely scrape by with my life
crawled in here and blocked off the exit
with those canisters I was gonna be one
yeah you're hiding in a cave and blocked
off space choice policy clearly
stipulates that dead
and as good as dead are two completely
different properties of matter unless
I'm dead I'm contractually obligated to
attend to my post I will report that
illegally grounded spacecraft if it is
the last thing I do
see those canisters by the entrance
Marauders come sniffing around in here
and I can take them all out with a
single shot not bad huh it's kind of fun
to like I ready give me your gun yeah
you sound a lot like my lieutenant here
hope this gun serves you better than it
did me all spacers choice weapons there
now thirty percent less likely to
malfunction
you've tried the best doubt tried the
rest shut up spaces choice yes I'm off I
just I like the idea of just like as
people are talking dirty art he just has
these like gears changing like he's just
thinking about what next to do like he's
oh that's that's a who me don't know
where you came from stranger but you
best keep your head down
there's Marauders hereabouts and worse
Landing violators call on that rung
leach landing in a veil without using an
official spaces choice landing pad it's
laughing with a fine if it weren't for
all these Marauders shambling about I
don't know anything you just said
no diffuse moderate Marauders non praise
you pulling my limb I mean yeah of
course Marauders bunch of addle-brained
derelict I could round them up all by
myself I just you know need a couple of
winks to catch my breath stretch my legs
some I wonder if picking all these like
like [ __ ] your answers is just gonna
make dirty already inherently caught
like confident and I'll you know I mean
like she totally was like wow you're
kind of a badass you're right okay for
sure no response though yeah that's fine
I don't like you it's a sword fight you
won't wind up
hello Murata please be informed that I
am authorized to use violent retribution
against unwanted solicitors failure to
do so will result in your immediate
destruction I don't appreciate being
talked to daily I have been programmed
to communicate with diplomacy and tact
please allow me to demonstrate
my deception protocols have failed I
have been programmed to express
disappointment I am programmed to take
orders exclusively from captain
Hawthorne if I accept your orders then
you must be captain Hawthorne do you
understand
[Laughter]
say this wouldn't happen to be your ship
with it because he sure walked in it
like it was your ship but if the ship is
yours well mister you owe spacers choice
a hefty fine great we got a dock your
pay I did not do this in my playthrough
my plane were you doing garden
[Music]
we got here hey don't go ambling out in
those hills
that's Marauder territory friend yeah we
know you talk too pretty for a Marauder
grunting yell hey you'd best head into
town avail yourself of Edgewater's high
walls and low low prices
Oh Artie pleased to make your
acquaintance [ __ ] bad shake your hand
but I've been hauling corpses what kind
of guy named Silas June you're in humour
for the town of Edgewater we're all part
of the spaces choice family I'll
probably be contributing a lot to your
graveyard Edgewater huh
oh my ear open up maybe we should check
out the old watering hole they got one
in here Tina no I know my language
[Laughter]
ken spacers choice beverage dispenser I
don't know what you're about but this
here is a spacers choice drinking
establishment I'm gonna fool me all I
see is a bunch of drunken slobs note the
bartender hey come on now that was
uncalled for some of us are still sober
you asked why it's taking so long fix
don't apologize just don't the camera
seems we've got a guest brilliant now
Parvati I do wish you'd spoken up I do
apologize I was given no forewarning of
your arrival or I might have welcomed
you at the gates myself
hmm I'm Reed Thompson outpost
administrator I cannot help but notice
you are not in uniform whoa dude let's
give a small talk I need a only
regulator with God has hooked up to the
town transformer did I ask you yes good
law no I don't want you killing anyone
least of all them my hope is that by
cutting off their power you will
convince those deserters to come back to
town before you go to the plant I want
you to stop by the botanical lab speak
to their leader Adelaide tell her the
powers about to go and that it's time
her band of deserters came back to town
okay cool Adelaide got it are you
setting off for the Vale cuz I know my
way around I mean in case you want a
guide oh here we go right with you mr.
Thompson don't eat her are you sure
I imagine miss holcomb will make a
reliable companion she knows her way
around the Vale sorry I you just want to
get out of here and you likely don't
want to tag along like me it's just mr.
Thompson has his own view on matters on
account of it's his job and what all but
that's not the only side of the tale
she's gotta earn her right
[Music]
if you're hungry there's meat turning on
the spit outside if you're bearing
illness find a place to lay your head
down and I'll fetch you a poultice
whatever your troubles with Edgewater
leave them at the gates and be welcomed
here
any questions dear
that'd be the garden dear you're
standing in a garden also fertilized so
mind your boo-boo read Dobson you here
on behalf of that cold-eyed reptile
that's here it
what's Reed's idea of peace then oh
really listening this isn't about power
I can't say I blame you
Reed is positively soporific like
everything else that comes out of
Edgewater that peace offering is canned
I in my own or living just fine out here
by ourselves why no seriously i but but
to do some release you can't visit right
go ahead he's got a regulator you want
ship parts you ought to rip them out of
the canneries guts and leave us be if
you're going down to the plant
you should divert power away from
Edgewater and toward our end of the grid
think about it
you'd be liberating an entire town from
a lifetime of service to that odious
cannery
I wanted to poke around in here alright
what the hell you're not real you're not
real
get away from me phantom shoo scram I
never talked this guy van van to hook
the phantoms never talked before well I
knew I shouldn't have eaten that Spratt
raw see see Higgins this is why you must
always boil your sprats before ingesting
Higgins phantoms got a name no you can't
possibly be a hallucination you're much
too dense
oh did he just say leave me alone yeah
someone else here hey mister
oh here we go
I just gotta ask you do you understand
what you're about to do
if you're sure I just had to ask
[Music]
he used to follow me around before he
left the cannery yeah we don't care
that's the thing about growing old start
to fail that's why is that what is seen
for the snake that you are chopped you
into pieces and roasted you on us spit I
want to ask you this in private away
from the eyes of my flock so they do not
see me lose my temper tell me why did
you do it I don't know how I present
buttons I guess you just put on airs
listen here whole head I'm only gonna
say this once I go talk to grace and
Thomas look them in the eye and tell
them their life here is over and the
only thing left to do is go back to
Edgewater and you tell Reed Thompson
that I will never return to Edgewater I
would rather die among my flowers that
live under his management I'm willing to
deal with it for ya are you offering to
cross Reed off huh
this some sort of twisted reparation for
what you've done you just looking for
some chaos he'll read if you must I
talked him into leaving if you can
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you just kiss I know it was great
kill to read Thompson you know my boss I
can't I need to leave I need to get away
from here I need to get away from you
yeah play play dumb mean to walk around
the table you can't help yourself huh
took a couple knocks to the cranium
let's just upon the veil on Oh God yeah
well that's gonna do it for this week's
episode of dirty RT stay tuned next week
we'll have another episode on Friday
Thank You Jake
we'll see you all next time see ya
you